لاول مره منذ 3,200 عام وبتعاونا مصري
انجليزي تمكن فريق من العلماء من اعاده
بناء وجه احد اقوى ملوك مصر القديمه الملك
رمسيس الثاني هي اول اعاده بناء عمليه
للوجه بناء على فحص بالاشعه المقطعيه
لجمجومته الفعليه وباستخدام نموذج ثلاثي
الابعاد لاعاده بناء ملامحه وهي عمليه
دقيقه جدا وبعد ما ظهرت صوره الملك في
شيخوخه حيث يعتقد انه عاشر 90 عاما عادوا
الزمان الى الوراء نصف قرن تحديدا ومن
الشيخوخه الى الشباب تمكنوا من الكشف عن
وجهه في ذروه» رمسيس الثاني ثالث ملوك
الاسره التاسعه عشر في مصر القديمه اكتسب
شهرته الخالده من تماثيره الضخمه التي
اشرف على تنفيذها اعتلى العرش وهو في
الخامسه والعشرين من عمره وحكم البلاد
لنحو 67 عاما
العديد من التقنيات المستخدمه في الكشف
وتنقيب عن الاثار التاريخيه ومنها تقنيه
الاستشعار عن بعد وتسمحوا بمسح الغابات
الكثيفه رقميه وتصوير التربه بطريقه تكشف
كل ما هو موجود تحت حيث يمكن هذه العمليات
اكتشاف ما لا تراه العين بشريه ايضا تساعد
تقنيه التصوير عبر الاقمار الصناعيه على
الوصول الى المواقع الاثريه الجديده ورصها
بدقه كبيره استخدام الاشعه تحت الحمراء
ايضا تخترق الاجسام اصبحت قادره على كشف
كل شيء مدفون تحت الارض وغير واضح المعالم
ويستخدم العلماء ايضا تقنيه الكشف عن
المعادن من اجل البحث عن اشياء المعدنيه
المصنعه والمدفونه تحت الارض والتي تقع
تحت عمق نحو 26 سم
[موسيقى]
من القاهره تنضم الينا دكتوره سحر سليم
استاذ ورئيس قسم الاشعه بالقصر العيني في
جامعه القاهره دكتوره يسعد صباحك شكرا على
تواجدك معنا لتشرحي لنا الاليه والتقنيه
تحديدا اول عمليه علميه لاعاده بناء وجه
لاول مره تتم هذه المره لاقوى ملوك مصر
رمسيس الثاني حدثنا عن التقنيه اولا التي
كشفت ملامح رمسيس في شبابه والعاده ترتيب
واعاده بناء هذه الملف كيف تمت الطريقه
[موسيقى]
وهو
العلوم واستخدامها في الاثار اعطت بعدا
كبيرا للاثار واعطت مصداقيه كبيره ومن ضمن
هذه العلوم اا علم الاشعه
واستخدامه في تصوير المومياءويات
هي اجساد
عاشت يعني لالاف السنين بفضل عمليه
التحنيط ومن هذه الاجساد المحنطه اا جسد
الملك رمسيس الثاني
واحنا في وزاره السياحه والاثار المصريه
وفي مشروع
الملكيه فحصنه عشرات من الملوك وملكات مصر
القديمه وبتقنيه الاشعه المقطعيه يمكن اخذ
الاف من من الصور واعاده تركيبها بواسطه
الكمبيوتر والسوفت ويرز متقدمه فيمكن
نعم
اللافت في المساله سحر اللافت في المساله
بانه كل اعناوين الصحف وايضا عن ناوين
مواقع التواصل تصدرت بانه رمسيس جميل
وجميل جدا هل هذا الوصف فعلا بانه
ظهر كجميل الملامح ام بان الصوره واضحه
هذه المره عندما نتحدث عن مومياء عمرها
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف عام برزت بوضوح اليوم
العمليه عمليه علميه
والملامح كما تريناها نسبه همم صدقها نسبه
عاليه جدا
وباستخدام المقاسات الوجوه المصريه
او ولد ولكن
الملك الوسيم هذا هو كان تعبيري وهذا هو
كان ردد فعلي عندما
اشتركت في
بناء وجه الملك فظهر بملامح مصريه
نبيله وسيمه همم يعني نجدها في في شوارع
بلادنا
فبهذا الوصف هو وصف دقيقه
ونتجا منه ملامح مصريه وهو بيحد ذاته همم
نوع من انواع النجاح طيب دكتوره دكتوره
المعروف انه يعتقد بالاحرى انه رمسيس
الثاني توفي كان عمره 90 عاما انتم رجعتم
بالزمن نحو نصف قرن اظهرت ملامحه هو شاب
كيف حصل ذلك
[موسيقى]
التقنيه هي تركيب وجهه باستخدام الكمبيوتر
على مجسم ثلاثي ابعاد للجمجمه
بوجود المكتبه الرقميه في الكمبيوتر
ومقاسات العضلات المختلفه محفوظه في هذه
المكتبه
بيعني تقنيات عاليه جدا يتم تركيبها
ديجيتلي على الكمبيوتر وبالتالي ممكن ان
احنا نشوفه في سن الذي توفي فيه وتسعين
عاما ونرجع باب الزمان الى الوراء باعطاء
نضاره اكثر للعضلات فيبدوا وهو في قمه
مجده العسكري
طيب سحر يعني بما انه انت كمان اشرفتي على
وجه توت عنخ امون من منهما اكثر وسامه بين
توت عنخمون ورمسيس وهل سنحسم الجدل في
وجهك كليوباترا يعني حتى الان ناس تعتبرها
يعني ايقونه في الجمال وهناك يعتبرونها
بانها ليست جميله على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
همم
مشروع اعاده توجه بناء وجه الملك توت عنخ
ام كان مشروع مختلف لم يكن همم
الجمجمه الرقميه ولكن الوجه نفسه تم
تمثيله على مجسم همم
وهي همم لا استطيع اخذ من اكثر وسامع ولكن
هي عمليه عالميه
والمقاسات هي مقاسات همم الجمجمه بالفعل
ومقاسات الوجه
المصري بالفعل فبالتالي ما ما نحصد عليه
هو نسبه يعني كبيره جدا من الثقه كلاهما
وسيمين همم كلامه ملكين عظيم وسيمين
بطريقه بطريقه
القصر العيني جامعه القاهره